ministers gathering this morning how's
your new Deputy PM for their fast
cabinet since last week's mini reshuffle
following The Reluctant resignation of
Dominic Raab forced out of Government
after two bullion allegations against
him were upheld one of them during Mr
Rob's time as foreign secretary Simon
McDonald worked alongside Mr Rob as his
most senior civil servant did you like
working with him
that's my answer
Pair worked together for almost 12
months Lord MacDonald said he warned Mr
Robb of his behavior before it escalated
to bullying but to no avail you're
saying that more Junior civil servants
said to you I'm finding working for Mr
Rob really difficult please can you talk
to him about it but don't mention me and
you tried to relay that and he didn't
accept that that's correct were you
surprised that he didn't accept that or
dismayed dismayed he was in control of
his behaviors I think he could have
changed his behaviors and he chose not
to change his behavior when you read the
report did you sing oh maybe I should
have done more given what happened in my
year with him uh you know I feel uneasy
but I still understand what I did do you
think he should apologize for his
behavior now yes pressure two on the PM
who rather than sacking Mr Rob in light
of the report accepted his resignation
and now wants to quietly move on Dominic
Rod said at the time if uh if that
investigation found against him that he
would resign and he's been good to his
word and has done that and I think it's
now right that we move forward but Lord
McDonald who worked as a civil servant
for almost four decades stressing Mr
sunac should do more to stick up for the
service he knows that ethos he knows
their quality so I hope that the Prime
Minister and other ministers do publicly
recognize that I think I would
distinguish sharply if I were the Prime
Minister between personal sympathy with
a colleague I'd worked well with I liked
and uh systemic sympathy Mr Raab spoke
of activist civil servants who had
agendas something this top Mandarin
disputes are you concerned that if
ministers and the Prime Minister doesn't
come out to kind of stick up for the
Civil Service the Civil Service service
will be unfairly vilified by all of this
that is a possibility because one aspect
is the Silence of civil servants that a
debate can rage about them without any
serving Civil Service participation the
characterization given by Mr Rob I think
is flat wrong
this close political partnership now
over but the Prime Minister still needs
his civil service to deliver policy
Bridges to build Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster